cuál de las siguientes expresiones es
equivalente a 7 am - el producto de
camas 1 y 2 camas 2 entonces serán 7 cam
- el producto de camas uno por dos camas
2 así que veamos para expandirlo por
completo necesitamos multiplicar estas
dos expresiones así que empecemos con
ello nos quedará 7 k - y ahora
multipliquemos estas dos expresiones
tendremos cap por 2 cam que es 2 k
cuadrada camps por 2 que es más 2 cam
después tenemos 1 por 2 cam lo que nos
da otro 2 cam y por último 1 x 2 lo que
nos da más
2 ahora hay que ser muy cuidadosos es
importante mantener el paréntesis aquí
ya que queremos restar todo esto así que
esto será lo mismo que 7 cam -
mantenemos el paréntesis y tenemos 2 k
cuadrada después dos camas 2 cam es lo
mismo que 4 cam más 2 ahora una forma de
pensar esto es distribuir el signo
negativo o también podemos pensarlo como
menos 1 que multiplica a todo esto así
que será lo mismo que 7 cam menos 2 k
cuadrada menos 2 k cuadrada menos 4 cam
menos 4 cam - 2 - 2 muy bien y ahora
veamos si escribimos todo esto con el
término de grado mayor al inicio
es este de aquí nos queda menos 2 k
cuadrada
este es nuestro término de grado mayor y
observando las opciones solamente hay
una que empieza con menos 2 k cuadrada
sólo una tiene como coeficiente a menos
2 en el término de cada cuadrada aunque
ya sabemos que esta será nuestra opción
correcta vamos a confirmarlo tenemos
menos 2 k cuadrada y después podemos
sumar 7 cam menos 4 cam lo que nos da 7
4 que es 3 entonces será 3 cam que es lo
que seguimos viendo en esta opción y
finalmente tenemos este menos 2 - 2 y es
exactamente lo que tenemos acá arriba
como primera opción